I STILL ICONTROOFS
R IN4 HIO VOLODYMY 2019.
HE'SNGS RIGHT NOW.OD TO E
FEEL, 3 POSSIBLE TPLN HO T?>> O
E HAVEATTACK
STY
ICTURE
ANOND 1s
HOISINO COME
HERE TO KILL AO KILL
>> Y YESTE
ANYOU SHOWED
HAVE A THEETOUHOW YOU ALL AR
FI'S BEIORTED THAT MAY BE  FY OD
THEM? WDO
WE SHOULDAVRIFLE, AND THAT BE S
AGGRONAIRPLANE
IEHEAM
WORLD.K RTATTACKOOEY HAVE UT
HERY
HIS IS THE HKRASHITM YOUR WHERE
AN UAIMI
HEOR
ERF CAUSALITY ONLDIERS,  SPATO N
DAY OF R AGGRESSION THIS  DISAS.
MINUTES THNETHTELY ONE OTION.I'A
R THTO STON ANOU AND WITH
THAT HAVE AEF.
AT TRAIN SILEICTIVE, INCLUD
ILES
KR SPTER W UKRAIAN, D RO HELP
HUE' U VER, YOU SAID,000 RUSAN T
-ULD BEIG IF OUMEDAY E INVI MI
ALTH SHOULWHHEIRY LEAIE CRAZY I
THE CRAZCT HUKRAINE,HANGE RDEROR
ANTH MILLION TIUGUTRLD.NEF UT T.
OR
FOR TRANSFORMING TNOMYTHE INTEGD
DEMOCRATIC,
DEAD RSI IO WORREANVTHE NAL JOUO
Y IS
SHRINKINSUF Y,
WHATIN IWEVER, PUTIN
WAG THOFFE ZELENSKYY
WAS FU
ISANY Y CT IN E UT PAUSE OANCEMP
DON'T TRTID,DO AOF
EXAMPLE, IN MAE HYBRID WAROFAS
HAERONSIBL
TERRORIST ATTACK
A E HE DISPAR, OTHERS.-- WT ME
?JUSTE THE INTERNATIONAL
NATION WHO SUFFEREMOTACK ANDURC,
IS A LIAR.
SA NOW, HOW WECAN -- IS LY ME  L
CORRESPONDENTS AS .
HELI.BEKYD SEE WITH THEIR O
LIVES THE RUSSE,
THE V
THVIL POPULATIONIEAND YOU OURNAS